[Music]
look absolutely gorgeous as you always
do and thank you know no one's looking
at me right now I'm the mop in the
corner you know I've got to say one of
my favorite things about Mad Men moving
forward and progressing is that now
they're into these styles I think this
is the sexiest period for women I you
know I've got to say those incredibly
short skirts I know this is sounding
incredibly pervy but you look at you
know when it was throwing the show
started it was the late 50s and every
was everyone was bundled up not having
it but now good god it's fantastic yes
are you gonna ask a question no I'm just
gonna keep I'm gonna keep we're not here
to find out are you is it fun to wear
these these styles great I mean I think
it's it's a it's really fun for me I do
believe the show has always been very
sexy I think even and it's more
restrained more sort of tightly laced
earlier years there was always a sort of
seething sexuality about it and and now
it's definitely coming more to the
forefront in terms of the costumes oh
yes yes I'm curious your character is
quite popular on the show you must be
getting recognized a lot for your
character on Mad Men you are you finding
that that people see you somewhere and
they say hey I know you from that men
the thing is yes it happens now which is
great and I was so excited to be
associated with with the show and to be
on the show and a part of it but I'm
always way more excited than the person
who's recognizing me a couple of weeks
ago and this woman stopped me on the
street and she said hey are you making
for Mad Men and I was like yes can you
believe it
and they punched her so hard tumble back
like quite a few stenum yeah you
shouldn't you shouldn't hit people when
they recognize you and compliment you
was she okay angry I was just so
enthusiastic about it and it's nice for
me it wasn't so nice for her you ever
have fans complain to you because
sometimes people get so attached to the
character they're not even really
they're not talking to you as the
actress who plays the character they're
more talking to the character well
that's and that's what's so interesting
to be a part of this shows it is people
do respond to the characters so deeply
but it does mean that sometimes somebody
will be like oh god I cannot stand your
character can we get our picture
together yeah I get that a lot I get
people that say I hate that guy you play
on TV Conan O'Brien I say well I'm chip
Whitley you know that [ __ ] someone
else